law-and-order true crime the Menendez
murders
this is I've already been hearing people
rave about this program and you play
their their therapist girlfriend I mean
it's one of those things where it's real
life is stranger than fiction when I was
reading the scripts I I just couldn't
believe this was all true but it's all
true it's so I mean it happened quite a
while ago I had forgotten some of the
details but basically they end up
talking to their therapist and then the
therapist feels like I can't disclose
this but the therapist tells his
girlfriend yes and that's remember when
you commit a murder make sure that the
therapist is single you know what's the
weird because before she went to the
police without evidence there was really
nothing they weren't being considered as
the mate I mean they weren't in jail
they were right yeah right people were
suspicious but they weren't so my
question is uh it's one of the strangest
things about that trial and then a bunch
of but a bunch of other murderers too
because I'm a murder fan I mean I want a
murder or be murdered is that I'm
curious a lot of women get attracted to
men that commit terrible crimes I was
asking you you know would I be more
attractive to you if I you know went on
a killing spree would they would you be
like wow that guy he's got the goods I
mean what does that what is that about
women now I mean I was researching
actually Ted Bundy because I had a line
in the menendez thing where I talked
about Ted Bundy I looked him up there
was a woman who was dating him and she
was calling the police and telling them
I think he's the killer that's killing
all these college girls and they finally
listened to her and they put him in jail
and then she still kept dating him she
continued to do that didn't break up the
relationship and he was a serial killer
when these women dead he would fix their
hair after well though he was so weird
it was so okay Thomas [ __ ] have you gone
down that alley anyway we were all with
you and you just took us down that road
we're on television this is a show
primarily for children and then you do
is willing to keep dating him until
finally he started this flirtation with
this lawyer who was defending him he was
already like clearly the man that had
killed all these people right and she
was jealous of his relationship with his
lawyer
that was what pissed her off she hear
that he's having sex and killing all
these people yeah I think that he was
murdering people I don't understand
these people that want to get engaged to
guys that are imprisoned right this is a
common thing to they get engaged to guys
in prison and they marry them but they
can't really have a relationship with
them they can't have sex with them most
the time yes well both of the Menendez
brothers are married and they're not
allowed conjugal visits so basically
you're marrying someone you're never
going to have sex well that's what
marriage is eventually that's what
America I put that at the end would you
be a good criminal do you think if you
turn to evil mmm if you find a play a
criminal yeah I'd be a fun role I think
you have great eyes very eyes like bug
eyes no I wouldn't your eyes are
beautiful your eyes are absolutely
gorgeous but they're big and that means
that you can with big eyes you can you
can act insane minor minor to BD you
know what I mean that could be like a
beady eyed cream but you have the big
eyes you can go you can go big eyed
crazy you know what I mean just yeah
exactly when I was a kid people used to
go all your to my mom and go oh your
daughter is so cute she has such big
eyes and I'd be like yeah I'd make them
even bigger tip yeah it'd be let me
thought you just ate a lot of lead
you